the gyro can experience a V I read war
the world's the opening line is
something like I can't remember the
opening I'm paraphrasing um
the earth was being we knew we were
being watched or what we didn't know is
we were being watched and that's a great
opening line for a sci-fi novel awesome
Martians are watching us and then they
send their ships and everything it's a
beautiful sci-fi novel because it's so
priests I did you notice I made up all
the side yeah and Welles really did make
it up like he knew nothing about
technology you know how the tripods come
out of this shit huh and they have laser
beams and the laser beam everything like
he just sort of made up it's gonna be
this beam of you know pure energy or
whatever like well you know what's
fascinating he did do that but that's
what a lot of people use as their
template for the future when they
thought about like future weapons it was
always a laser beam it was always a beam
well I think what's once physics were
understood that things were in particles
there wasn't that big a jump that there
would be it
first of all Zeus's Thunderbolt the
ultimate yes you know sure I dude yeah
just I mean this Thunder in general it's
the idea of this power this electricity
fan everybody knew what electricity
wasn't what it could do I would have
loved to been alive before electricity
was explained and see what the fuck
people were saying you know I mean did
you imagine what people were saying back
when you know people barely had a
language they barely could string
together a sentence you would understand
and the fucking sky bolts of light
coming out sky and hitting the ground
balls through a field to deal with you
know there's been an instance that I
read about on of ball lightning like
there's been several instances of ball
lightning that they think explains UFOs
yeah I would think that a lot of not all
UFOs obviously but some UFO sightings
they talk about these orbs that are
flying orbs of light apparently under
certain geological pressures like
certain pressures on near fault lines
and the like there's there's fucking
bolts of lightning that like come out of
the ground I would be surprised it's
yeah it's supposed to in Atlanta it can
last for like three or four seconds well
if everything in the world isn't
to charge everything is totally makes
sense right just a weird spark you know
that occurs what is this never seen yeah
really exciting my wife and I were in
Capri once and it's a little island off
the coast of Naples and is that he
laughs oh well I think they're saying
this is ball lightning yeah yeah I could
believe it would be ball lightning kiss
ball lightning can has weird properties
yeah look look at that just disappeared
it's a federal role and it sweet writer
than fuck so you can see it from miles
away right right
and you will like me hit things you know
how you always see spark a shit well my
wife and I were sitting at we were
having dinner and this and it's a little
island and a big storm brew started
brewing on the Mediterranean and all of
a sudden everything you know the ozone
in the air and your hair starts to stand
up and it was a light breeze and Capri
smells like lemons and bay leaf so it
was really beautiful and I said to my
wife here and this is what a rabbit
smells like right before the lid comes
down on the floor bay leaf in lemon and
then hey and then we sat on the balcony
of our hotel and the storm never hit
Capri but it was several miles away and
we watched it and it just just giant
lightning strikes out in the clouds
but it never got close enough to rain
you know what I mean
oh that's great and it was the I said
this is like watching the gods play
right like here we're sitting here with
a glass of wine and the air is electric
Wow and all you you'd hear it you know
and then you you know you see it and
then you hear it afterwards because it
was that far away then now you need
clouds to have lightened yeah and the
clouds are just crashing together and it
would you'd see like what I'm saying is
where you were you didn't have to worry
there's no clouds above you you didn't
have to worry we were it was at least a
couple of miles away
Wow so you guys yeah clear Mediterranean
sky simply that you could feel the
raised electricity in the air because
there was a breeze blowing and and your
hair was on and and there was a lot of
ozone you know yeah from all the
crashing but it never got close enough
that never hit the island and never
poured rain it just sort of stayed right
off the island and I was
that's so exciting if I could always
have storms to spectate you know because
you'd watch a ball just watch shoot from
one cloud to another or arcing rope you
know and and it was endlessly
entertaining there's nothing more
entertaining than lightning you know
then the the noise of the Thunder and
that smell of especially if you know
you're not gonna die that was what made
it so great we were sitting there with a
joint and a glass of wine it was like it
you know yeah heavenly cuz if you're in
a city I live here in New York City no
storm goes on you have this weird
feeling that let lightning can hit this
fucking building at any time and my
windows could explode I was on a plane
with my wife going into Frankfurt
Germany for the World Cup like in 2006
and we flew through a giant electrical
storm mm-hmm so we're on the plane and
I'm looking out the window and the
planes bouncing up and down and a giant
ball of lightning struck the wing of the
plane
oh my watch out like this and then my
huge humming noise the lights dimmed for
a second and went right back on the
plane like oh my god flight attendants
went fucking white which then I was a
little scared because I thought well
they shouldn't be freaked out right and
my wife like was you know panicky and I
went not that I was so great but I went
the wings still there let's start there
right the wing the wing is completely
intact yeah it's a lightning rod at the
end of that you know the little metal
thing they have at the end of the what
do they have a metal thing yeah yeah - a
transplant exoskeleton thing around them
so right and lightning it's it's
disperses around the planet Earth Oh
prepare for that yeah yeah obviously you
have to write because they're gonna fly
feel like just do that look at that
picture oh my god planes you never hear
about planes blowing out because they've
got hit by look at this watch this Oh
though it's crazy cuz in then when you
see it in real life it looked like
nothing looks so fast yeah let me see
what it actually is so we it got hit and
then the pilot didn't come out for like
ten minutes that rot he led us all sweat
and everybody was scared shitless maybe
then the pilot came on and he talked
like Kissinger he was German obviously
but he first you didn't German then in
English but when he spoke in English she
sounded like hisses you
there's nothing to worry about this
lightning is harmless and everybody's
like oh my god
what's going on here but it was scary
this is the Turkish airplane hit by
lightning strike inside playing video
but I don't know why there was sparks
going look at the door the doors all
just got hit right there and the lights
go out
terrified the mountains does shit's
terrifying shut it off don't ever put
that back you know flying through the
sky where the fucking gods are angry I
think did I tell you this week if I've
told it all stop we flying Australia
clear sky and what was on a little plane
usually you're on a giant plane and then
it was on like a 737 you know like that
you original version Australia which is
groovy airline so on the flight with me
and my wife has the game you know this
guy is a rapper right he's on a tattoo
and his dad and Carrie Hilton who's also
rapper and uh and their policy right so
it's hectic right it starts to get bumpy
and the pilot comes on it goes like
everybody strapped in okay for like ever
and it Australia's 15 hours 16 it's long
yeah this is all day and this lasted
literally five hours right just bouncing
up and down side to side pitching you on
the whole thing and on them on the sky
map right it says like Pago Pago 1500
kilometers meaning you're 1500
kilometers from panko panko in other
words the Pacific Ocean is so big
there's no land masses nothing anywhere
near you where you're going over right
so you're not gonna go in because it's
turbulence it's not your fucking freak
man you're not gonna die this is an
electricity turbulence doesn't make
planes crash and it doesn't unless
there's some sort of shitty a structural
defect on the plane like that you know
the wings aren't glued on
I mean any a structural defect I'm
thinking about generally you've been in
a planet turbulence they know you know
that's not what makes them cross you
know but anyway said it's terrible in
any case so we get through it and next
morning the wrappers get up and they're
all like oh my god I thought I was gonna
die and you know it was so bad last
night I you know I was praying and lo I
they're all really shook up and Carrie
Hilton is a very lovely young rapper
lady wakes up it's been all night mind
you well no one can move I stopped
holding my wife's hand for five you know
like this what happened and the rappers
cuz you didn't feel we're gonna die no
hurry alright she goes I took a pill I
didn't see anything and beans a
motherfucker yeah what and then she ate
one piece of fruit and put on a leopard
miniskirt and came out with her makeup
and signed autographs and I was like
you're a star I want you on my team you
are Alexander the Great we everyone was
scared are the adrenaline you could
smell in the plane you know what I mean
from five hours of bouncing you know
just not oh you know you want it to stop
stop so we can stop producing and she
just woke up work yeah if I can put on a
push-up bra getting ready to for the
photo call when they got the plan I
believe you did tell the story I
remember this place herself there was
like you got to be kidding me man yeah
it was either this podcast or another
podcast I heard you Tori it's remember
it now after it's over we talked about
the girl getting out and changing yeah
that's a great story
well it's great that someone could be
that that out cold on ambient so there's
positive things to ambient I was talking
about shit about ambien
but if ambien can get you to avoid that
not one minute of it and it lost the
forever I'm sorry I didn't mean to
repeat it but it always made me laugh
because I was scared to death and when I
got off the plane I look like you know
something James Brolin sat on I was
squishy and moist hmm
what's your dance per day yeah and you
know you just wrecked and all I wanted
to do is like you know eat a club
sandwich and die
you know cuz you're like God we're on
the ground and she just like hey who's
for pastures